Things You Missed In The Cloverfield Paradox
and ARG
A few days ago we were all sitting there watching
the Super Bowl and Bad Robot dropped a new
Cloverfield movie faster than Tom Brady managed
to drop that Lombardi Trophy.
But before I can get into the Things You Missed
in this new Cloverfield movie, let's do a
quick quick recap of everything in the Cloverfield
films and ARG so far, because I will be referencing
back to them.
If you aren't familiar with ARGs, it stands
for Alternate Reality Game.
In other words, it's a viral marketing technique
that was used to create buzz for each of these
movies, primarily through the creation of
websites and twitter accounts that live within
the Cloverfield universes.
They typically drop cryptic clues and leave
the fans to decipher their meaning to unlock
the next piece of the puzzle.
And one other thing -- the Clover ARGs are
considered canon.
So most of the ARG for the first Cloverfield
movie takes place on the Tagruato website.
If you aren't familiar, Tagruato is a Japanese
mining company considered to be the most advanced
in the world and known for their deep sea
oil drilling stations that can drill miles
and miles further underwater than their competitors.
Some people believe it is one of these drilling
stations in the Atlantic that awakened the
dormant Cloverfield monster, or possibly monsterS
in 2008.
But aside from deep sea drilling, they also
own several subsidiary companies, like Yoshida
Medical Research, a deep sea bioprospecting
company.
What the heck does that mean?
Basically they study deep sea creatures in
extreme environments to see how they survive
and how that can be applied for human survival.
Tagruato also owns a technology firm called
Bold Futura, which develops technology for
military and space exploration.
That includes developing satellites, so obviously
we'll be coming back to that one.
Then there's ParafFun!
Wax Distributors, though it's unclear how
that one ties in with the other subsidiaries.
The last one is a beverage company called
Slusho!
the company that Rob, from the first Cloverfield,
was planning to move to Japan to manage.
Slusho!
famously uses a secret ingredient called Deep
Sea Nectar known to make the consumer feel
happy and have numerous health benefits.
Some people believe that this nectar is extracted
from the egg of the Cloverfield monster and
that the drilling station in the Atlantic
near New York City is actually collecting
this nectar.
This is because the parasites that come off
of the monster are found to have high levels
of the nectar in their blood.
That leads us into the first ARG which is
about a group of extreme environmental activists
known as TIDO Wave who go to this Atlantic
station to try to expose Tagruato for some
kind of dark secret that they are supposedly
hiding there.
The station is destroyed in late 2007 and
Tagruato blames this extremist group for attacking
it.
However I'll show you the video and let you
be the judge of what happened.
"The incident is being coined an environmental
disaster and a matter of life and death for
almost 300 individuals aboard the large deep
sea drilling platform.
It went down days ago and only now are we
beginning to learn details regarding the oil
rig collapse and what may have caused such
a devastating accident.
This dramatic home video captured by eyewitnesses
on the scene shows a large oil rig in the
middle of the Atlantic Ocean suddenly sinking
under violent and explained circumstances.
The destruction of the Chiuai drilling station
happening dangerously close to the coast of
Connecticut sending hundreds of workers scrambling
for help as a large oil rig collapsed.
Video footage shot earlier show signs oil
is possibly seeping from the big rig into
the sea.
The dark shape below the surface appears to
be an oil spill that could easily mean a nightmare
for the shoreline of Connecticut.
Yeah.
Oil spill.
Shortly after, this happens.
The final extraordinary clip clearly shows
the sheer speed and power of the sinking vessel.
It appears that the oil rig is being sucked
down at a dramatic rate.
But what causes the shower of debris that
followed remains a matter for intense speculation.
Shortly after in May 2008, New York City is
attacked on the evening of Rob's going-away
party.
His brother, Jason, is killed by what appears
to be a tentacle monster destroying Brooklyn
bridge.
Rob finds out that Beth, the girl he's in
love with, is trapped in her apartment.
He sets out to rescue her and is joined by
his late brother's girlfriend, Lily, his friend
Hud, who serves as the cameraman and Marlena,
a girl from the party.
Marlena gets bit by a parasite and dies.
They save Beth, and Lily gets away on chopper
#402.
Rob, Beth and Hud aren't so lucky and that's
where first movie ends.
But actually there's one more thing though.
The Cloverfield incident is recorded on Rob's
tape camera.
It's accidentally recording over Rob and Beth's
trip to Coney Island from one month prior,
where something can be seen falling into the
ocean.
OK, that's where the first movie ends.
I can't say for sure quite yet, but there's
a good chance that everything in 10 Cloverfield
Lane and it's ARG take place in another dimension,
where the New York City attack hasn't happened
yet.
And I promise, this all ties back into The
Cloverfield Paradox, so hang with me.
In 2009 a military analyst named Howard Stambler
joins Bold Futura, the satellite company I
told you about, and seven years later he is
honored on Tagruato's website as employee
of the month.
According to the website, Howard’s drive,
commitment and refusal to accept easy answers
resulted in a significant breakthrough diagnosing
transmission complications with two of their
government satellites.
At some point, Howard's ex-wife takes custody
of their daughter Megan, and he goes a bit
crazy, creating a website designed to appeal
to her and send her secret messages.
Meanwhile, he's building a doomsday bunker.
He later kidnaps young girls and makes them
wear Megan's old clothes to fill the gap left
my his daughter.
In 2016, he uses the secret website to urge
his daughter to runaway from her mother and
come home to take cover in his doomsday shelter,
suggesting that something huge is about to
happen.
His daughter never shows up, and Howard gets
desperate and finds someone to fill the role
of his daughter during the attack, and that
person is Michelle, the protagonist of 10
Cloverfield Lane.
Howard finds her at the Kelvin gas station,
follows her, knocks her off the road and she
wakes up in the bunker.
It's just her, Howard, and a man named Emmett
who helped Howard build the bunker.
When Emmett and Michelle find out that Howard
was lying about his daughter, they devise
plans for Michelle to escape.
Howard finds out about the plans and kills
Emmett, but Michelle gets out to find that
the air is clean, but worm-like aliens have
taken over the Earth.
She escapes toward a possible survivors camp
in Austin, which is the end of 10 Cloverfield
Lane, but the ARG extends a little bit past
that.
A box left by Howard is found containing data
about a particle detector from the International
Space Station that picked up two huge bursts,
followed by a massive red flash that occured
everywhere, presumably the same event described
by Emmett as the beginning of the cataclysm.
The next event happens in January 2018, not
long before the release of The Cloverfield
Paradox, so I'm going to go ahead and fire
up that Things You Missed counter.
Machine.
That I have.
Let's just take a short commercial break while
I do that.
--
The ARG for The Cloverfield Paradox actually
began in-real-life in summer 2017 at San Diego
Comic Con, where fans could actually purchase
a Slusho! from the mobile Slusho!
truck at the event.
Each Slusho flavor had its own robot mascot,
which is probably due to the fact that the
studio behind the films is Bad Robot.
There is actually a seventh robot, who was
a combination of each flavor.
This seventh robot appeared on the Slusho!
snapchat filter.
If you aligned the seventh robot in the blank
space left on the truck and showed the Snapchat
to the Slusho!
employee, you were asked to fill out a form
to win a prize for solving the puzzle.
That would be just the beginning though.
On January 18th, which happens to be the 10
year anniversary of the original Cloverfield,
the Tagruato website is updated, but upon
trying to access it, you'll receive an error
message, however, examining the image behind
the error message leads to a text post that
reads as follows:
TOKYO – January 18, 2018
Tagruato has begun development on a revolutionary
new energy technology.
In what Ceo Ganu Yoshida called a technological
great leap forward for our planet/ This renewable
technology will take at least 4 year to complete
with along with another six years international
regulatory bodies to bring the powerful revolutionary
energy source by April 18 2028.
I think we can make the conclusion that the
energy technology referenced is "Shepard"
from The Cloverfield Paradox.
I believe that the ARG, like the other two
ARGs before it, takes place in real time,
here in 2018.
The movie, which doesn't occur until the Shepard
exists, takes place in 2028.
The thing I'm not sure about yet is whether
it takes place in Dimension A, the Cloverfield
universe, Dimension B, the 10 Cloverfield
Lane Universe or Dimensions C and D, two theoretical
entirely new universes.
I'll give my arguments for each possibility
as we progress.
But I think whatever Dimension the movie takes
place in is not our dimension, the one that
you're watching this video in right now.
I'd say the internet browsers in that universe
work slightly different, so if we access the
webpage in Google Chrome, Firefox or other
popular web browsers from our universe, the
page glitches out.
I wouldn't rule out the possibility that someone
in our dimension can build a browser that
will read the page properly, maybe we just
haven't discovered it yet in the ARG.
Moving forward, not much happens to the website
until January 27th, when it becomes possible
to spot a graphic about something called The
Cloverfield Energy initiative.
This time, there is faded handwriting on top
of the graphic, but manipulating the image
allows us to see the true message.
It says "Someone needs to stop this from happening!!!
This is nothing but a cover for a reckless
experiment that will reset the world's grid.
Stop this to save the world.
T.I.D.O.
Wave."
If you'll remember, TIDO Wave is the same
group that opposed Tagruato's deep sea drilling
project back in the era of the original Cloverfield
ARG.
Also on January 27th, the first winners of
the Slusho!
truck puzzle challenge I mentioned earlier
received their prizes in the mail.
The prize package included a Slusho!
bobblehead, a certificate of congratulations
with trademarks registered by Bold Futura,
the satellite company Howard Stambler worked
for, and a pamphlet version of the Cloverfield
Energy Initiative graphic spotted on the background
of the Tagruato website.
The most recent update to the Tagruato website
introduces a Hebrew news article from 2007
that talks about road closures near the Dead
Sea, possibly because of sinkholes.
As a reminder, that would be a little over
a year before the New York City attack, that
is, if it even happens on this timeline.
Let's go back to the release date of Tagruato's
new energy source, April 18, 2028.
If you go to 04182028.com a distorted video
plays.
This page also continued to update over the
course of January, and we get little bits
of information piece by piece from what appears
to be a guy wearing glasses.
Some of the lines we can make out include
the following.
A male voice says: "That is why I'm trying
to warn you about the dangers of what Tagruato
is trying to do."
In an update, a female voice can be heard
saying, "Welcome to the show...
Cloverfield Station... joining us today...
controversy...
Mark Stambler, author of the book..."
So this Mark Stambler has the same last name
as Howard Stambler, the guy who built the
bunker in 10 Cloverfield Lane.
The latest update from the 04182028 website
looks like this.
In case you couldn't make it out, Mark Stambler
says, "This experiment could unleash chaos,
the likes of which we have never seen.
You have no idea how much I would love to
be wrong about this.
It would be no fun for me to be right.
If you wanna know more, read my book, ..."
There was also a Mark Stambler Twitter account
at one point.
Some users who attempted to DM the account
received a message containing more cryptic
videos.
Unfortunately, they are very hard to decipher
because he actually sent them as vertical
videos of the computer screen as opposed to
just sending the actual video file.
The account is no longer up, and the only
tweets were about some hoax at the university
he works at and how he had to notify NYPD
about someone watching him.
This information actually doesn't directly
tie into the movie, but I just thought I would
mention it because it tells us more about
the character and it makes me think that someone
from Tagruato has a reason to keep an eye
on this Mark Stambler character.
OK, so as of right now, that's as much as
we know from the ARG, but before I tell you
the things you missed from the movie, there
is one more thing that I'd like to point out
in the trailer.
It says 10 years ago, some thing arrived.
Now.
Find out why.
Then it immediately cuts to a shot of the
Shepard.
I would say that could support the idea that
The Cloverfield Paradox takes place in Dimension
A, but the event caused by the firing of the
Shepard could take place across multiple dimensions,
which I will explain later in this video.
Early in the movie, Ava and Michael are in
a huge line at a gas station -- and it's the
fictional Kelvin gas station, which is also
where Michelle stops to get gas in 10 Cloverfield
Lane.
If you pause on that shot, you can also get
an idea of how bad the energy crisis discussed
in the movie really is.
The sign says "Gas Available Today" as if
that is a rarity and it costs $30 gallon.
There’s another appearance towards the end
of the movie which may suggest that Kelvin
was in on the Cloverfield Energy Initiative.
When Ava gets back in the car, she asks her
husband if he's moved yet, and he jokes, "forward
or sideways"?
However this could also be a foreshadowing
of the journey taken by those aboard the Cloverfield
Station later in this film.
If you're looking at a timeline, they continue
to move forward in time but they also go sideways
into a different dimension.
While we're on this topic, I think now is
a good time to bring up the logo and poster
of this movie.
And before you start to say that it's just
a poster and it doesn't matter, remember that
we have seen clues on the Cloverfield posters
before.
But this time I specifically want to look
at the logo.
If we look back to the 10 Cloverfield Lane
Poster it has one timeline leading from the
Cloverfield text to the place where the movie
takes place.
But this Cloverfield Paradox poster looks
all too familiar for someone who has spent
time studying split timelines.
This logo is definitely supposed to represent
the timelines of the two dimensions occupied
by Cloverfield Station.
One of them comes off the letter L, which
could mean that the dimension that they travel
to is Dimension B from 10 Cloverfield Lane.
Before they get their gasoline, there is a
blackout, which Ava says is the fourth or
fifth one of the day.
In both prequels, the calamity started with
a blackout or multiple blackouts.
"Ahh!
Oh!
Oh God!
Oh my God!
What the hell was that?"
"Power still hasn't been restored to many
cities on the Southern seaboard with this
afternoon's widespread blackouts."
During the opening title sequence onboard
the station, we see the team picture of the
international crew.
After they cross over to the other dimension
a different photo is seen.
They also have this tank of worms which are
supposed to be there to consume bacteria,
but they disappear after crossing over.
Worms are later found inside of Volkov, but
these worms look much smaller than the ones
in the tank.
If the dimension that they travel to really
is Dimension B, then could it be possible
that the disappearance of the worms aboard
the spacecraft is related to the appearance
of vicious worm-like aliens in 10 Cloverfield
Lane?
Let me know what you think in the comments.
Ava has a video chat with her husband where
he tries to bring up the idea that maybe they
should try to have kids again after the accidental
death of their first two kids in a fire.
"We can't go back in time and know what we
know now."
However, the ripple created by the firing
of the Shepard seems to occur at different
places on the timeline in different dimensions,
so maybe the idea of going back in time isn't
that far fetched.
It also sets up the later plot point where
Ava finds herself with an opportunity to save
her children in the other dimension.
While they are preparing to attempt to fire
up the Shepard again, Acosta tunes into to
an Earthican TV broadcast and we finally get
to see the full video that had been teased
on the 04182028 website with Mark Stambler
being interviewed live.
The title of his book is The Cloverfield Paradox
and his Twitter handle is @Paradox_Is_Real,
which is a real account created in January,
the same time the online portion of the ARG
started, but it hasn't posted anything yet.
Here's what Mark has to say about it.
"That accelerator is 1000x more powerful than
any ever built.
Every time they test it they risk ripping
open the membrane of space-time.
Smashing together multiple dimensions.
Shattering reality.
And not just on that station.
Everywhere.
This experiment could unleash chaos.
The likes of which we have never seen.
Monsters.
Demons.
Beasts from the sea."
So while this guy may appear to be crazy for
the time being, he turns out to be 100% right,
so where does he get this information?
Let's also not forget that Mark's brother,
Howard Stambler knew exactly when the calamity
was going to hit in 10 Cloverfield Lane and
what it was going to entail.
In the ARG he tried to get his daughter to
come down to his bunker well in advance.
He jknows he's low on time before the disaster
happens, so he knocks Michelle off of the
road.
Emmett explains that he was nearby right then
the huge flash hit and he raced straight to
the bunker, where Howard was already closing
the door.
Howard knew exactly how to prepare for what
was coming and he did.
So the question is: how did these brothers
effectively predict the future when nobody
else could?
That could be a question answered in another
movie.
Let's continue Mark's speech.
"But not just here and now.
In the past.
In the future.
In other dimensions."
This could be the key to understanding how
everything we've seen so far is linked.
Let's assume for a moment that we're dealing
with four entirely different dimensions.
Maybe at the time that the Shepard overloads
in Dimension C, Dimension A is still only
in 2008, so the Cloverfield incident occurs.
Maybe at that same time in Dimension B, it's
still 2016, so the 10 Cloverfield Lane attack
hits.
And maybe Dimension D is parallel, and the
event destroys their Cloverfield station.
There is more evidence outside of just taking
Mark Stambler's word for it to suggest that
this is one event taking place in multiple
timelines at different times.
Let's revisit Emmett's description of the
event that triggered the cataclysm in 10 Cloverfield
Lane.
"The attack I saw myself."
"What do you mean?"
"I was on my way home from work.
And it looked like a flash.
Bright red.
Like an explosion from way far off.
Wasn't like fireworks.
No this was more like something you read about
in the bible."
"So what you saw, what a flash of light?
Lightning?
A fire that flared up?"
"I'm not explaining it right.
This wasn't like anything I'd ever seen."
Seems awfully familiar after seeing The Cloverfield
Paradox.
Another connection to 10 Cloverfield Lane
can be found in Michael’s social media feed
after the first explosion.
First of all, I do hope we’re running on
a 7G network in 10 years.
But the posts are all talking about a huge
noise, several missing city blocks and part
of the city in rubble.
But one of the posts is a question asking
if anyone’s been outside and wondering if
the air is safe to breathe.
A quick note, when Michael saves the little
girl, he puts on a Cartoon for her called
Bleep Bloop, which appears to be about the
mascot of the production company Bad Robot,
but could also have something to do with the
robot flavors seen on the side of the Slusho!
truck.
It’s more likely a reference to Bad Robot,
since in the credits it says the animation
was created by JJ Abrams and Ben Schwartz
and Bad Robot is JJ Abrams’s company.
Here's another interesting bit.
During the Shepard overload, the whole station
starts shaking and we see a shot of the Slusho!
bobblehead, the same one that Comic-Con fans
in 2017 were given for solving the Slusho!
puzzle!
This is the first of many parallels to the
first Cloverfield movie.
Another theory that I have is that the dimension
that The Cloverfield Paradox takes place in
is the same as Dimension A except for the
fact that the Cloverfield incident hasn't
happened yet.
This time instead of happening in New York
City, it's happening in Space.
An early reference to Slusho!
just before the disaster strikes is just one
of many parallels we'll see.
When they find as rescue Mina, she has a beam
lodged into her shoulder in the same spot
that Beth is impaled by a beam when they rescue
her in the original Cloverfield.
Speaking of Beth, she reaches out to Rob via
her cell phone to let him know she’s trapped
in her apartment.
In The Cloverfield Paradox, Michael reads
on his cell phone about one of his friends
being trapped in an apartment after the calamity
hits.
The person is trapped in 402 Pa St. That may
or may not be related to helicopter #402 which
Lily gets away in during the first movie.
In this shot we can see a monster in the background
wrecking a city with huge skyscrapers.
It’s assumed this is somewhere in the UK
but we never find out what city it is.
And finally, in order to save the space station,
they have to prevent it from tilting off axis
by 25°.
Beth’s apartment is also tilting off axis
by just under 25°.
They end up going to the building next to
it and the three main characters have to traverse
the ruins of the roof to get to the door that
they need to get to.
The scene where the astronauts had to cross
over to get to the other part of the space
station is almost identical.
And then there’s the villain of the movie.
In this movie, Mina is portrayed as the villain,
even though she’s just trying to help her
own planet.
We don’t know a whole lot about Clover but
it appears that the destruction caused by
it is just due to self defense instincts as
well.
When we first discover Mina they hear the
sounds of Clover’s roar on the other side
of the wall.
And when Mina is on the attack at the end
of the movie we can also hear the distant
sound of that roar.
And of course, Cloverfield ends with a mysterious
object, which is assumed to be a satellite
or space shuttle, crashing into the Atlantic
Ocean, which is exactly where the pod from
The Cloverfield Paradox lands.
And while this does answer some questions
about what caused the calamity in each movie,
it also raises plenty of questions.
What role did Tagruato have in the opening
of this space-time tear?
And how do all of these films fit together?
I’m going to talk about the three most plausible
scenarios.
Scenario Number One.
The Cloverfield Paradox takes place in it’s
own universe -- Dimension C. The firing of
the Shepard causes time-space tears in all
four Dimensions and monsters, creatures from
the sea and demons travel to earth through
these tears.
The event pushes Cloverfield Station into
Dimension D and when they overload the Shepard
again, they push themselves back into Dimension
C.
This would explain why there is never any
mention of a previous calamity in either sequel
and why Clover appears to be much much bigger
than the monster in Cloverfield.
This is the easiest and least creative scenario,
and wastes the opportunity to tie in the object
landing at the end of Cloverfield to the shuttle
landing in Paradox.
Scenario Number Two.
The Cloverfield Paradox takes place in Dimension
A, 20 years after the New York Cloverfield
incident.
After the events of Cloverfield, the monster
is captured or goes back into hiding.
However, an accident caused by Yoshida Medical
Research causes their Cellular Growth Accelerant
used for healing injured humans to blow Clover
up to a much bigger more destructive size.
When they fire the Shepard this process is
sped up and it creates a disaster on Earth,
while the space station is pushed into Dimension
B.
The Paradox causes a huge flash which gets
the attention of the aliens -- possibly the
Martians
"Russians are developing some nasty stuff
and if the Martians finally figured out a
way to get here, their weapons will make the
Ruskies like sticks and stones."
Who set to wipe out human life on the Earth.
They fire the Shepard again and come back
to Dimension A at the end to find it in ruins.
Scenario Number Three.
The Cloverfield Paradox takes place in Dimension
C. The Shepard tears space-time so that disasters
also happen in 2008 and 2016 in Dimension
A and B respectively.
When the Shepard is fired they travel to Dimension
B or D, but when it is fired again to get
back home, they actually unknowingly go to
Dimension A, which is similar to their Dimension,
but Clover has been growing and on the loose
for over 20 years.
But that of course still doesn’t solve the
question of what landed in the water at the
end of Cloverfield.
Unless…
Scenario Number Four -- they went back in
time to 2008 Dimension A, but that doesn’t
explain why Clover is awake and GIANT at the
time of their landing, while in Cloverfield
there was no issue until a month after the
object landed.
There are so many possibilities here so if
you have your own theories leave in the comments,
I’d love to piece this one together, but
chances are we won’t get answers until a
future movie.
And there’s also a possibility that the
ARG for this movie isn’t over yet, so if
you’d like to see me cover any updates we
might see, let hear you in the comments on
that as well.
If you were confused at any point in this
video, go ahead and leave a like.
My name is CZ and I love talking about psychological
horror, but honestly my brain is pretty racked
on this one.
But regardless I’ll be back with new horrors
every week so make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld
and ring the deathbell so you can see those,
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.